madame née toussaint canal pourquoi le
choix d'un cadeau parce que ça hier on a
fait un pari tous ensemble et c'est
salon s'est passé c'est faux ce qui
s'est passé tout sur moi par hasard
regarde non mais vraiment cinéma voilà
c'est pas parce que j'ai triché
non parfois bon dos et ousmane nakano
nommé
accordez nous aurons le même qu'à
d'autres que moi et chérie charlottetown
un cadeau oui ma soeur anna cadeaux tout
m'ont amenée à cagnes je vais éliminer
tout de suite je vous le dis je ne sais
pas du tout ce qu'il ya dans les bois je
vais éliminer tout de suite le cadeau de
gide je t'aime beaucoup j il était
bientôt cadeau c'est génial vous pouvez
pas faire ça s'il vous plaît je leur en
ai jamais rien je vous le monde mais la
relève le cas de max un cadeau variable
c'est quoi un cadeau remarquable
alléchant gourmand by maradona
maxime qui suis-je ici marani baqouba à
défaut d'avoir un éclair de génie
voici un éclair de génie j'ai appris
qu'ils devaient éliminer jeckle
tout l'après midi ce cadeau bâtisse en
pierre mon travail c'est la première
fois moi je me suis dit comme vous aviez
la coiffure aussi plate que la libido de
gilles verdez j'allais vous offrir un
petit peigne avec de la laque
oui c'est pourri merci je vais une étude
parce que je suis sûr que c'est un truc
qui a fléchi de jradou vous allez déçu
oh là là le haut le livre de christophe
j'ai déjà le livre de joe starr à lire
et toujours et lève le pied lève le pied
on a encore vu un truc sur snap sur
moynier arrive levier bébé et a pu la
joker ses gardes
alacchi je faire enlever
je vais enlever je vais enlever le
cadeau de gilles non vous n'êtes pas
faire ça à ses fils et moi et moi vous
expliquer pareil c'est pas seulement bon
cadeau si c'est vrai que moi c'est
quelqu'un qui vous aime et que vous
appréciez ces fatou qui a fait ça avec
moi toute la matinée on a pensé à vous
ils voulaient pas me faire ça il était
tellement heureuse
non je vous en supplie pour l'instant si
c'est pas tout je garde c'est la vague
de lancer la balle
c'est la grêle tellement meilleure
voiture
j'ai enlevé un cadeau de richesse que je
suis sorti une bonne encore un truc vous
allez regarder un truc assez ci abrite
ici non je sais vous en avez déjà ça
c'est vrai que ça fait un peu doublon
mais qu'elle ya tellement de fans
voulaient bouffer ça va une paire de
rois de remplacement vous avez une
maison monde sud où joue aux boules
il ya pas mal de gens qui peuvent plus
supporter money il paraît une
apparemment tu avais perdu une boule où
je vais enlever mais charlotte j'te
kiffe sert il a un jeu la dorna
mais non mais c'est pas grave je sens
pas ton cadeau ça je te vois c'est un
cadeau toutes races qui est triste en
fait c'est les a priori que tu vois ce
que je veux dire être attractif ou dans
des états pour rien tu peux citer l'un
de ses gardes il ya trop de gens qui
m'aiment
oui tu ne le vois pas cet amour avec moi
merci c'est quoi mais tête mais c'est un
truc dans ma loge tu te fous de ma
gueule
je voulais pas avoir le maillot de gaz
clape ce que j'aimerais que tu l'avais
invité et en fait j'ai pas trouvé
et puis après j'ai pas eu le temps et
dans ta gorge avait un truc divine donc
à moi pas venu en béton cadeaux dans vos
pas vous vous pouvez pas faire ça vous
en avez besoin maintenant ça va de vous
est indispensable je vous le promets
vous regardez moi dans les yeux ce que
je vous ai déjà menti c'est non non
c'est pas beaucoup parlé de gens
l'aiment gens et vos cadeaux de benjamin
il a pas nous ayons ce moment personnel
non c'est vrai qu'ils étaient chez moi
voilà la affective et sentimental et en
plus financière fait une énorme erreur
si vous faites ça fait un gros connard
verdi c'est dur là pour vous même pas
loin kelly non je rêve le cadeau
d'isabelle non non ça mais alors là
franchement mais franchement je tenais à
la production du centre pour aller là
bas pour aller pour aller vous achetez
ce cadeau j'ai pris sur mon temps de
déjeuner je cherchais je cherchais j'ai
réfléchi c'est tout un symbole
en plus c'est un manager vous et vous le
carré vous voulez
j'ai même laissé poules mouillées leurs
25 ans quitte donc le cadeau quoi c'est
pas possible c'est beau mais ça va
changer ta vie
sur les devises la zizi oui chérie j'ai
froid j'ai un truc et on propose it tous
les cadeaux qui reste je vais les ouvrir
à pain et en sachant ce que je sais ce
que c'est je vends choisir ok donc souf
tous les canaux et je vais choisir le
cadeau que je préfère le cadeau de
vincent un petit effort là en fait le
cadeau d'un sens des mines direct non
non non non il ne faut rien un paquet
cadeau en plus que j'ai fait moi-même
avec ma fille chez moi un amour fait on
voit là tu voyais le petit les petits et
c'est pour ça madame b effect tu vas
kiffer taha al islam annonce et cabano
se vendent bien dites moi j'attends des
sottises noda
donc ça se sait que cette faute et
qu'est-ce que vous avez ramené vous pour
moi qui fais pas de tête à briquet saisi
non s'il vous plaît je suis plus chic et
cela quand même le studio françoise une
invitation approfondie de pole dance
pourquoi on doit déjà med pour lé boss
son cadeau c'est pour vous prouver qu'on
est entouré méreau traçant les nous mène
et en plus ça va voir trop beau alors
pour détourner de mer aux et la vérité
génie bingo dokdo maintenant non j'ai
changé d'avis et finalement éliminer
cadeaux directement voilà enfin d'ouvrir
quand même mais si les chiens et là
c'est moi c'est le garde pour l'instant
j'élimine le cadeau qui ne s'est jamais
mine fatiguée j'ai pu rentrer à la
maison ce soir c'est vous ferez quoi
cela sert il fait pas ça à ckoi produits
qu'elle a choisi spécial nord vous en
vous regardant à la dit que vous étiez
beau mais comme vous travaillez beaucoup
c'est pour donner un petit coup d'éclat
à la peau elle a choisi cela avec amour
fatto dit que c'était beau ah ben voilà
toujours la télé doit région vous êtes
mon amour mais malheureusement j'ai
éliminé mais c'est vrai que
l'échantillon 28 grecque
se réjouit pas vos boîtes a bien appris
à l'ifa non j'ai lu mines gecamines un
cadeau du ciel
on ne sent pas il est trop gros bad
revient à 2 non je ne sens pas chez
apple c'est un ouvrage bouteille est
saisi pour parler plus grand risque en
tentant pas en faire un données étant
devrait être donné ce truc aventure
c'est michel qui était en sursis
c'est pas moi que c'est mon fils mais
c'est un amour cet homme oui je
l'endroit stone cela d'or thomas kevin
faut aller voir merci monsieur lui mais
j'ai dû vider le câble objet d'une jolie
mine terry
gagnez des cadeaux c'est à dire un truc
moi bien sûr votre ami malik bentalha
way m'a dit que vous faisiez du s en
zizi je me suis permis de prendre du m2
devenue folle finir c'est déjà pas mal
vous pouvez faire les vôtres j'élimine
localité l'île alors oui pourquoi les
jeunes à bien jouer après avec ma
meilleure amie s'il vous plaît justement
réservé mais ce n'est pas vraiment mon
mari
juste des cadeaux attention il reste
qu'on a trois cas dopage ama
agathe isabelle a donc il ya deux
cadeaux de vieux un cadeau tiote
tadic c'est un truc que des gadgets da
longtemps qu'il avait chez lui une
prison je veux éliminer les gens
arrêtent de me tutoyer
j'ai quand même un temps fort but est
que tout à l'heure a fait les beaux
jours texte comment tu vas mais quand
même je connais du crédit de monde
descend de trois étages a proposé trois
ans avec les magic system
non ce serait une très grave erreur
environ secteur qui joue avec nous
voyez ça lui plaira aussi je pense mes
cadeaux alors oui c'est sûr c'est une
scène de vos passions j'ai tapé dans
l'oeil obligé de deux façons vous savez
le boomerang joseph isabelle il reste
trois cadeaux est-ce que vous quoi il
doit prendre votre cadeau mois en
investissement sentimentale entend en
marche à pied oui moi si ça ne l'est pas
ça me parle et vous retrouvez sans avons
quoi demain ça défibrillateur j'enlève
défendable cadeaux sûr que votre cadeau
est fou lâché sur qui va vous plaire ça
c'est sûr a way avait bien sûr quoique
j'ai pas confiance en vous et coûte cher
mais en v3 tout impair sait manier coupe
pas devant ce magnifique à mon cher le
relève le cadeau de benjamin castanet
les alisiers les nichoirs l'année un
très bon jour novell choix très bon
c'est quoi mauvais choix c'est beau
c'était un c'était un choix qui avait
chez moi avec une inscription dans très
important mais c'est non sans délai
c'est vraiment un connard ouais j'ai
perdu un beau cadeau vous avez le
certificat tout le temps sinon je n'ai
le gazon well as rien le garde c'est
énorme
benjamin merci en tout cas ça dommage
pour l'amener chez moi maintenant
ouais alors il me reste le cas de la
devise et j'ai les boules j'ai les
glandes
j'ai les crottes de nez qui pend au nez
sur tropiques fm c'est ce qu'il faut
savoir quelle animatrice surprofit
humanité toujours surtout piquer le fond
c'est comme ça qu'on s'est connu
d'ailleurs mais pour d'autres détails
mode écoute de la musique en bois du
tropicana
j'adore cette radio le témoin de cas de
gale
je mets ta g ou votre cadeau celui
d'agathe les chéris je vais là j'ouvre
le choisir le cadeau que je choisis
choisi 3e choix tôt je vais prendre le
cadeau d'isabelle
mais prend d'autres cadeaux donc tu
élimines son héros de khartoum a pas
offert tac je prends un cadeau d'agathe
merci quand même
bah oui bon je faisais pas fini alors
sinon sinon j'ouvre le vôtre mais je
prends celui d'agathe succès mais pas
laisser les gars mais le mieux mais les
symboliques et vous pouvez leurs membres
mais je pète un plomb du clash c'est
quoi alors je vous le savez combien ont
tous les ronds ouais donc c'est un très
bel objet sans verrou l'hérault en quoi
je subis un mot et tout c'est un homme
sinon pour te rappeler que le paf et
plein de blaireaux pour le reste et
porteront encore plus beau jeudi le
trépied vous sortez très bien là ça va
j'ai rien fait je tente de faire une
chanson d'amour pussy scotché eh ben on
voit que ses beaux yeux mais je n'ose
coach rtl la session pas de ce côté là
commence tu ne veux pas que mon patron
ne sont pas cessibles immédiat le prix
sur la tête de ma mère mais elle a gardé
le prix
le trépied et sur la tête de ma mère que
les gars c'est cher c'est juste et
rennes nantes a payé sa 120 le trépied
continent attention mais n'ont même pas
longtemps ça me fait beaucoup de peine
ce soir mais double katchina mail vous
voyez d'aspirine exactement les trois
chiens et franchement je suis
franchement ça me gêne pas les laisser
la mecque a été la fuite ou qu'elle je
t'aime trop doit l anniversaire m est en
amour bon je peux pas le prendre parce
que je n'ai pas choisi exprès de laisser
les prix ça doit tomber ton mec il a de
la barben peut maintenant mais si vous
le reprenez mais non j'ai pas loi et
pourquoi j'ai pas choisi ce cadeau
allez le coq il avait tu sais que tu m'a
touché deux fois la cible il doit fuir
le public c'est quoi alors ces mini pitt
mais pour s'enlever la boîte quoi mais
tient pas ils ont élaboré et voilà et
ouais pas mal et 2 je préférais le
cadeau 10h me suis trop de cadeaux 10 h
il a jamais j'oublierai ce que tu as
fait la voix te dire tu verras tu verras
ce que je ferai pour toi et le qu'une
blairon bon ben c'est bon ça va c'est à
dire est qu'elle est une maladie pote
docu police